émotion hier soir émotion sur ce soir
aussi grâce à vous à l'instruction et
laurent voulzy bonsoir bonsoir je me
détende aime les plus connus de la
chanson française
donc vous allez chanter tout à l'heure
oui oui on m'a chanté tout à l'heure
vous allez chanter vous allez sentir un
peu chacun notre tour et puis ensuite
ensemble chacun son tour pendant
plusieurs heures pendant plusieurs
heures a bien évidemment moi je chante
dix sept heures loin je ne chante que je
ne chante que 14 heures c'est quasiment
10 non-stop
merci en tout cas de nous dire un petit
mot direct de la rochelle parlez nous un
peu de ce climat des francofolies que
vous connaissez bien la ville
la ville est en fête ses 1 les
francofolies
pendant six jours je crois que toute la
ville de la rochelle ne parle que de ça
n'est prise que par ça et c'est assez
formidable en plus il fait très beau
c'est une ville magnifique que je
connais pas bien et c'est vraiment un
événement formidable qu'est ce qui est
ce qui est bien aussi c'est que c'est
que les gens qui sont pas très très au
courant de ce qui se passe dans la
chanson moi je rencontrais des gens un
peu partout qui me disaient qu'ils
étaient au courant que je venais
francofolies pour s'adresser à moi comme
ils seraient adressés à d'autres gens
d'autres chanteurs qui venaient ici ça
veut dire que ce que le que les
francofolies ont pris un une ampleur
considérable
alors justement on le voit bien on voit
bien le dynamisme grâce à foulquier
qu'on va retrouver tout à l'heure de la
chanson française
mais curieusement quand on parle de la
langue française parlée cette fois on a
le sentiment que les francophones sont
un peu sur la défensive est ce que ce
n'est pas un peu paradoxal que les
francophones sont 100 sur la défensive
en ce qui concerne la défense de la
langue française parlée la langue
chantée française elle se porte bien et
la langue parlée on est un peu sur la
défensive
c'est à dire moi je trouve que ce qui
s'est passé pour la langue parlée
récemment avec la loi toubon et on n'est
pas très menacée je trouve pas qu'il ya
un gros danger mais le danger il est
plus pour les chanteurs d'être ce que
disait charlebois tout à l'heure le
rouleau compresseur américain de lessac
sont en général ça c'est sûr mais sans
ça la langue je vois pas tellement où
est le problème que de temps en temps il
ya des mots anglais qui arrive ou
italiens ça ne me dérange pas et laurent
voulzy est-ce que vous exportez bien les
chansons françaises
on ferait pas vrai non non non un peu
quoi il ya des chansons alors alors oui
il ya des chansons qui sont un peu
passées à l'étranger par des enfin
paradoxalement malheureusement ou
heureusement sont des chansons où il y
avait les des mots anglais dedans comme
le soleil donne rockollection il ya un
lien il ya quand même il ya quand même
un problème nous en france on se porte
bien avec la chanson française je trouve
pas trop mal quand même
même si bon mais la chanson française à
l'étranger
il faut pas rêver encore du chemin à
faire quoi enfin ces voix là est bon et
on compte sur les deux ambassadeurs que
vous êtes merci nos efforts bon
spectacle merci voilà nous faisons
entendre des artistes confirmés mais les
français